Bali was I went there with no wig no
clip-ons no weave no makeup because I
couldn't do that here because they had
already released fake fat photos and
everybody was calling me an obese Pig
falling off I couldn't defend myself and
then I saw women writing me saying I
really look like what you look like in
those pictures so am I an obese pig that
fell off too what was your message back
to them no I had a big mirror in the in
the house that I was living in I
wouldn't look in it and I did a couple
times and I was like I am so ugly
and like I ca I'd get naked and I'd look
in it and I'd be like I'm so ugly like I
saw everything wrong with me
and then one day after a couple months
of I mean I studied ayurvedic medicine I
was doing Theta healing Reiki healing I
was doing DNA D encoding because that
generational trauma will get you every
time I was doing I was doing breath work
I was doing Wim Hof ice baths I mean I
was practicing alternative medicine to
the highest levels it was I want to
produce a show about it and it helps
save people celebrities and regular
people it saved my life
okay let's talk about this music let's
talk about couples goals let's talk
about it um the thought is that it's
about your relationship with Pauly D yes
that is correct yes I know that artists
work through what they've been through
yeah so you just felt like you needed to
put it in the song so I was I feel that
I was gracious
um with what I put in the song you sing
apparently to one of his girlfriends and
the lyric is poor poor girl you think
you got the whole world but he's just
giving you the same show
[Music]
same story as before did you give him a
heads up at all that you're doing this
song or have you I'm I'm here he had me
blocked on everything the second that he
got you know he's he's the pictures were
off the Instagram and I didn't know the
phone number an hour later when he hears
it what do you think he's gonna
he's he's still living in his ego likely
so he'll respond with that I don't have
one anymore I did two weeks of PTSD
shrooming in Bali aubry's talking about
treating her post-traumatic stress
disorder with the Psychedelic compound
found in magic mushrooms she says the
experimental therapy also helped her
kick an addiction to a powerful sleep
medication what I learned at 17 was
Ambien
and I couldn't sleep on planes I was the
only one in identity came that like
thought she was going to die on an
airplane because I listened to that
Alanis Morissette song too many times as
a child you know that one day he got on
the airplane he thought everything was
cool went down
[Music]
so like I had those I just have always
had a fear of flying and we used to take
three or two four planes a day we'd
start out in morning radio we'd be at a
MySpace event we'd be on tour we'd do a
after party we'd need to be on a plane
into hours to the next place for this
same thing for years it was like that so
I just couldn't sleep and they put me
with the doctors and the doctors gave me
Ambien and said this will help it's not
going to have any side effects you can
get maybe two hours on a plane and you
won't wake up groggy
the former Danity Kane member was a
contestant on the fifth season of the
Celebrity Apprentice in 2012. Donald
Trump Jr played an advisor role and
Aubry claims they had an affair you
really felt like that was real for you
the relationship with Don Jr was real
yeah I was always waiting for another
girl to come forward like how all these
girls came forward with Trump
I was always seeing will there be
another girl that comes forward and says
that they had a relationship with Don Jr
and that they were called certain names
or that they experienced certain things
that I knew I experienced and then maybe
I was just
nothing maybe it wasn't everything he
said it was because he used all of those
words before me soul mate I want to have
a child with you all of these things
were words he was using not me it's hard
for me to sit in interviews and say kind
things about the love I shared with him
because
what he has become is unrecognizable to
me
I don't know if that was always him but
he was something else with me or if what
he was with me was his last ditch effort
to not have to be
what he was born as which is Donald
Trump's son
he was born under a name before he ever
had an actual personality and presence
he didn't have many options to go in
different directions like the rest of us
do
at that level of power
relationships are arranged people lie
about every lies are very common
everything is a protection of the family
there are a lot of realities that exist
in that world at that level of power
that even I couldn't understand I had to
ask him what does this love mean
sometimes right you know I said to him
my friends just think you're having an
affair with me and lying to me he's like
okay well then let me meet with your
friends
let me meet with your mom let me meet
with everybody and tell him exactly what
I feel and he did and then they all
believed me
and then it didn't feel like it wasn't
real at all and it didn't need to be
announced to the world
but it everybody around me knew what it
was
and so I I don't know I mean until the
day that it was over I felt like it
would never be over it was very intense
I had like a two two and a half hour
conversation with him
after
everything went down and um I taped the
whole thing I've been in therapy over it
for years now I've played it just sat
with my therapist and played it and
analyzed it and analyzed all these
things and my my therapist told me at
one point like you're gonna have to see
this as a death you're gonna have to see
this as your husband woke up one day
went to get milk for the cereal because
you guys were out he got in a car
accident the car is in shambles and he's
dead on the street and he's not coming
back
and you're never going to be able to be
with him again and this 2018 moment
still feels stunning and surreal for
Aubry watching Kanye West with President
Trump in the Oval Office there were
comments made about Kanye West that I
overheard being in that family and the
day that I woke up from an ambient Blitz
I looked up and they were breaking news
cutting into whatever Show on MSNBC to
show us Kanye and the Oval Office with a
make America great hat on hugging Trump
and Don Jr's there and everybody's there
and I looked at it and I just said to
myself this is the fakest
excuse my French bleep this out this is
the fake I've ever seen in my life
listen you are you are talented you are
an artist I mean you I've been watching
since Making the Band I can't believe
it's been almost 20 years girl there is
also this school of thought that
women can't work together do you think
girl groups are healthy so I am the
forever Optimist when it comes to girl
groups I have brought Danity Kane back
multiple times I listened to a clip just
the other day when y'all were on a radio
show and honey y'all were singing yeah
we did we did singing and I think that
was what was really special about us we
were we were the first we were the first
singing television show we were before
American Idol would you do that again
with the girls with Danity Kane would
you get back together with him you guys
did as a trio in 2018. I would forever
be back with sanity Kane I'm the one
that's brought us back every time and
I'm not the reason why it was ended
either I don't care if I didn't get
along with any of them but I do but if I
didn't I would always want it to come
back will it no the other girls don't
feel the same way I do